vielen dank ich habe ein thema
mitgebracht was mir am herzen nicht
deutschland ist eines der ältesten
länder der welt das ist erstmal keine
schlechte nachricht denn menschen werden
gesünder älter in deutschland das eine
gute nachricht großer zivilisatorischer
fortschritt gleichzeitig sage ich wir
werden aus eigener bevölkerung den
wohlstand den werden heute haben heute
haben die arbeitskräfte die wir heute in
deutschland haben nicht aufrechterhalten
können deswegen meine these deutschland
muss endlich ein modernes
einwanderungsland werden in der
vergangenheit sind sehr viele fehler
gemacht worden menschen sind
eingewandert in die sozialen
sicherungssysteme das war falsch wir
müssen den arbeitsmarkt endlich breit
öffnen es gibt demografen die sich damit
wissenschaftlich beschäftigen die haben
vor einigen jahren mal ausgerechnet dass
jede familie in deutschland sieben
kinder bekommen müsste um diese so
genannte demografische lücke zu
schließen das heißt meine these modernes
einwanderungsland für deutschland das
ist übrigens auch ein projekt im einzel
vertrag und ich sage an der stelle auch
einrichtung von der dr dr -titel man die
union hat in den letzten 16 jahren hier
nichts gemacht das ist ihr ist
touristisch historisches versagen und
deswegen wird die ampel liefern
ja
es stimme ich zu weil wir müssen beim
thema zuwanderung mehr differenzieren
das geschieht oft nicht in der
diskussion ich sag's mal ganz
holzschnittartig wir brauchen viel viel
mehr zuwanderung von qualifizierten
fachkräften und wir brauchen viel viel
weniger zuwanderung in die sozialsysteme
bisher ist es umgekehrt und das hat
einen ganz einfachen grund weil die
zuwanderung in die sozialsysteme ist
relativ einfach du gehst seine grenzen
sagt s wort asyl und in dem moment bist
du erst mal im verfahren drin was
mehrere jahre dauert und egal wie es
ausgeht wo auch die wahrscheinlichkeit
also bleiben kannst relativ hoch ist
während wenn du als fachkraft zu wann
bist dann hast du unglaubliche
bürokratische hürden abgesehen davon das
hat mir vor eines der länder mit den
höchsten steuersätzen soll ja was auch
nicht unbedingt attraktiv die
zuwanderung dann auch noch eine schwere
sprache dazu also wir haben vorgesorgt
in ganz viele hürden und dann noch die
zusätzliche bürokratische hürde also da
müssen wir unbedingt was dagegen tun und
es gehängt aber auch beides zusammen ja
wir müssen andererseits und das finde
ich nicht gut bei der ampel auch ganz
deutlich wirklich mal diese zuwanderung
in die sozialsysteme
reduzieren weil das am ende dazu führt
dass die akzeptanz von zuwanderung von
fachkräften sind weil die meisten
menschen oder ich sage nicht die meist
über viele menschen leider nicht zu
differenzieren die sagen dann einfach zu
wandeln will ich nicht mehr her und
deswegen sage ich wir müssen tatsächlich
das bei dem ein sagen ja brauche
unbedingt und bei dem anderen aber auch
nein und bei dem ein glaube ich auch
gerne dass die ampel jetzt was machen
wir mehr zuwanderung von fachkräften
aber bei dem anderen thema glauben sie
mir einst dass sie mit den grünen und
mit unserer innenministerin wie wir sie
jetzt haben eine begrenzung der zahl das
thema hinbekommen also da bin ich ja
sehr sehr skeptisch
da müssen wir dann bin ich darf die
dinge differenzieren humanitäre
flüchtlings migration asyl das ist auch
rechtsstaatlich gebotenen sogar meiner
sicht gerade jetzt in der laudation die
wir gerade auch darin wieder spricht
keiner aber sie haben recht die
situation 215 war ja eine solche die
deutschland ja auch
gesellschaftspolitisch fast auseinander
gerissen hat das darf nicht passieren
aber der druck natürlich auf die
einwanderung in die sozialen
sicherungssysteme ist so groß weil das
andere so versperrt ist das heißt du
nahe dass andere öffnen na klar viele
menschen haben lust durchzustarten viele
menschen von denen die kommen die
zurzeit über das asylsystem das
flüchtlings system kommen die wären viel
besser aufgehoben als reguläre
einwanderer und an einem punkt möchte
ich herrn dr dr -titel man widersprechen
nämlich es geht nicht um hoch
höchstqualifizierte und promovierte
menschen sondern es geht um die ganz
ganz breite masse es fehlt überall im
handwerk 10.10 hunderttausende von
arbeitskraft allein in deutschland
fehlen glaube ich 70.000 lkw-fahrer dh
diese these es geht nur um spitzen
qualifizierte das ist ausdruck land war
mein weg 230.000 handwerk vielen dank
für den hinweis also es ist dramatisch
der chef der bundesagentur für arbeit
spricht von einer nettozuwanderung von
400.000 die wir brauchen jetzt muss man
da sagen warum um unseren wohlstand zu
erhalten damit die renten stabil bleiben
das hat ja alles ein grund also die
müssen ist so machen ich will
zusammenfassen wie moderne
einwanderungsländer kanada australien
neuseeland die machen das sehr klug seit
vielen jahrzehnten wir haben es noch
viel nötiger und ja das ist ein auftrag
deswegen macht sich die ampel da auf den
weg also wenn ich da weniger bemerkung
zu machen möchte erstens finde ich es
darf überhaupt kein zweifel sein dass in
deutschland das asylrecht gilt und dass
wir hier eine verantwortung eine frage
das ist total wichtig weil manchmal wird
als erstes gesagt was wir alles nicht
dürfen sondern aber dieser fakt steht
und wir unterscheiden dort auch nicht
nach flüchtlingen aus syrien oder aus
schwarzafrika wenn es um asylrecht geht
oder aus der ukraine da gibt es keine
unterschiede es gilt die rechtslage ist
für alle gleich das muss man immer
einmal sagen zweiter ich bin sehr dafür
bin sehr dafür dass wir erst mal
feststellen wir sind ein
einwanderungsland und dass wir dort
deutlich moderner werden schneller
werden das war mal in der großen
koalition der letzten legislatur das
stand im koalitionsvertrag dass die
verfahren verkürzt werden sollen ist was
los auf drei monate ja und was ist die
realität ich weiß 15 usw es ist extrem
lange wir müssen dort deutlich schneller
werden ich wünsche mir ein modernes
einwanderungsgesetz da haben wir
erhebliche differenzen wenn wir es
konkret machen vermutlich aber das ist
weiter gar nicht schlimm wir müssen
endlich grundlagen schaffen bei uns auch
in meiner partei gab es eine breite
diskussion dazu wird auch durchaus
unterschiedlich gesehen das finde ich
nicht tragisch aber endlich dort eine
regelung weil lange zeit war die these
wir brauchen kein einwanderungsgesetz
das war die these im bundestag die
mehrheitsfähig war und diese these die
ist einfach nicht stimmig will müssen
die vielen dinge die es bereits gibt
zusammenfassen und da hoffe ich dass die
ampel dann wirklich vorliegt handelt und
das dann auch so entsprechend das werden
wir sicherlich ganz kontrovers
diskutieren aber dass dann eine
grundlage da ist weil das ist glaube ich
dringend notwendig valentina empfindest
du deutschland jetzt schon als modernes
einwanderungsland oder haben wir da noch
einen weiten weg zu gehen meine
persönliche einschätzung ist dass wir
noch einen sehr weiten weg zu gehen
haben ich glaube da sind wir uns ja sehr
ähnlich nina und ich sind junge frauen
die machen wollen die das
leistungsprinzip fördern ich habe das
gefühl dass wir uns aktuell auf nur ich
hab keinen migrationshintergrund ich
schon und ich komme aus einer
gastronomie familie also ich bin die
erste in meiner familie die studiert hat
worauf ich sehr stolz bin merke aber
dass es durchaus unterschiede gibt und
das ist fakt und das spüren wir auch
tagtäglich aus welcher familie man kommt
oder nicht das ist einfach so dass kann
man den menschen auch gar nicht übel
nehmen sondern es einfach ein
unterschied wenn ich in der familie
aufwachsen die gewisse kontakte hat die
ein gewisses netzwerk hat die gewisse
erfahrungswerte im berufsleben hat oder
es ist ein unterschied ob ich aus einer
gastronomie familie komme die sehr
einfach lebt und das schätze ich auch
sehr und da soll man auch nie vergessen
wo man herkommt dennoch das gibt einem
werte mit die andere so vielleicht nicht
mitbekommen aber es ist dennoch ein
unterschied weil man viel weiter hinten
anfängt als beispielsweise kinder einer
akademikerfamilie und ich finde wir
müssen da irgendwie eine
gleichberechtigung schaffen aber wir
müssen vorsichtig sein weil in diesem
ganzen gleichberechtigungs debatten
leider entwickeln wir uns dann in eine
richtung die dann wiederum auch
diskriminierung oder benachteiligung
genau für die andere seite